- My name is Michelle Khare,
and I'm a professional cyclist
for the BMW Happy Tooth team,
and today I'm challenging
legendary stuntman Andy Bell
and his Ferrari to a race.
(rock music)
I have no idea how today is gonna go.
- I'm going to just be
chewing my fingernails off
if I'm sitting dead stop
on the 405 in this car,
600 horsepower just waiting to be used
and going zero miles an hour.
(rock music)
- I am the reigning U23
national champion for cycling,
and this year is my first
year riding as a professional.
Today, I'm gonna be riding
some pretty sweet equipment.
It's basically the Ferrari
equivalent for a bicycle.
- I'm a professional
stuntman, race car driver,
race truck driver, part-time daredevil.
Pretty much do it all.
2011 Ferrari 458 Italia.
Doesn't need much
explaining, I don't think.
It's got that yellow horsey on the front.
That means it's pretty badass.
- Today's race is very different
from any normal cycling race.
We will be battling regular
Los Angeles traffic.
- We're gonna be taking
two different routes down
from up here, the top of Topanga Canyon,
to Santa Monica Pier.
- That is necessary, because
bikes can't go on the highway.
- [Woman] On your marks!
(engine revving)
Set!
Go!
(peppy rock music)
- [Andy] Let's hope
for no traffic up here.
Oh, come on!
Don't you know we're racing?
Carpooling the Ferrari.
- Woo!
Yes!
- [Andy] Oh, no! What?
Aw, man!
You beat me!
- I'm sorry, man!
- What the hell, Michelle?
- [Michelle] Traffic, I guess.
- [Andy] Seriously, yeah.
- [Andy] Obviously.
- [Michelle] Ferrari can't
- [Michelle] even beat traffic.
- How was your ride?
- It was great.
We hit about 40 miles an hour
going down the first descent,
which was super scary but super fun.
Kinda like driving a Ferrari.
- I think you had me by what,
like six minutes or something, right?
- Yeah, it was really close.
- Accidents and people getting in my way,
and then red lights,
the exit here in Santa
Monica was terrible, so...
Give it A, not only did you
win, but you also got fit,
and I just got fatter sitting in the car.
Maybe I can just get one of
those baby things that you sit
behind you
- [Michelle] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Andy] and I could
just like, have a beer,
and you can just tow me around.
- [Michelle] Okay.
- [Andy] Okay, look--
- [Michelle] We can do
that next video (laughs).
- [Andy] That's way better.
I'll put a Ferrari sticker on
the side of it or something.
Thanks, Buzzfeed.
Good times.